oh il est flou
[Musique]
ou mon ami Angelo a traîné la sabage
dans les petites rues chanté babellouè
parmi les murs cou blancs quand le
soleil éclate écrasant la caseb et
desséchant le bled marieus s demi il
disait que le Nord commençait juste
après les tours de Carcasson et le voilà
jeté par le coquin de s s les ciels de
printemps lu semble
d'automne ma
patrie j'ai tout laissé là-bas quand
j'ai fait la
valise mais comme les autres
[Musique]
idallah parole d'honneur mon frère c'est
dur de tout
quitter abandonn dans la terre où tavais
t
semé
soleil soleil de mon pays si beau ici tu
retombes en
morceau la fée de nous autes tu fais la
fête qu'X
escarau dis faut arrêter de sa sendrire
laoumoun pourrait
revenir en lui appris dans sa petite
école que ses ancêtres blonds
s'appelaient les Gaulois et pendant des
années il a cru sur parole lui qui est à
peu près blanc comme Enrico Matias titit
d'autre faubour il a cherché Gavroche
mais ils se sonent souvent compris bien
de travers si ses espoirs parfois sont
partis en brioche il sait des oasis au
milieu du
désert ma
patrie d'amis il y a pas BF monsieur
Corneil
peut-être les voix comme il doivent être
mais ça qu'est-ce que c'est ça c'est des
chall la vie c'est
Laia de l'auberge
[Musique]
Espagno que tuapportte ma parole compte
avant tout sur ça
[Musique]
mergise mergise mon si beau
pays c'est pas les hot dogs de
Parisot les hot dogs qui me rendront mon
appétit dis on va se taper une belle
bouffa la vie qui vient dans les bras
lorsque j'ai des soucis on a le pied
noir je m'en viens respirer dans l'air
que place et c'est toi l'exilé oubliant
sa disgrâce qui me donne en
riant son
[Musique]
espoir